sandra clop is a diving instructor with
nearly 20 years of experience she has
cave dad all around the world she's here
to show us some of the diving equipment
rescuers used to save those kids
sänger clock good morning good morning
so you have the full face mask there
that the kids were wearing why was that
so important so this is important
because if the kids get any water inside
of a normal scuba mask or a normal
regular panic and there's nowhere to go
they cannot go straight up how easy is
it where would it be for a young boy
who's never doesn't even know how to
swim let alone put on something this
complicated to put that on keep it on
and go through what they had to go
through to get out they need a lot of
psychological strain to be able to learn
how to clear this mask in a very short
amount of time if any water did get in
to learn how to equalize though there's
the things that people have an intense
class on Wow and they probably just had
a quick instruction we learned that
there was one dr1 diver rather with the
young boy and then another one trailing
behind what do you think that was built
for that was built for the the safety of
the kids so they're probably carrying
the the tanks for the for the boys so
they're gonna have a longer hoses a
7-foot hose when they're going through
that restriction one by one they've got
a diver in front of them and then the
boy it sounds like was coming out with a
long hose seven foot hose attached to
the tanks carried by somebody else and
it's a challenge for a healthy person to
carry all of this equipment not to
mention the psychological stress we hear
that these boys were week two of them
may have had lung infections how risky
was it for them to go through this
process just given that the main risk it
would be panic I believe because again
they cannot go straight up they have to
go out so they have to remain calm if
they feel uncomfortable then they just
have to really focus on on staying calm
because when you start to move around
and panic you can let water into this
system it's it's a pretty good seal on
these things but still you want to treat
them gently and how would in a normal
circumstance and then give us your
thoughts about how it would have worked
in this case how do you communicate with
other people that you're in this water
that was described as being as in like
chocolate milk
we use light signals and in cave diving
and if there's some diving if the
visibility is even worse and if they
stir it to nothing then we have touch
contact we do but it takes a long time
to train to be able to to do black out
scenarios where you can be in touch
contact and communicate by touching each
other and these boys don't have time to
do that training
Sandra based on everything you've heard
this morning would you call this a
miracle getting them all out I think
they were in very competent hands it was
it was a world-class team that was out
there that knew what they were doing and
I think the boys felt safe in those
hands and if anybody could get them out
it was the team that did it they kept
them calm they told them what they
needed to know and they took the boys
diving through through a cave there was
something they diving I know incredible
sander Club so great to have your
expertise thank you so much